hello and welcome to this video playing
JC Korea's from Argentina yeah I'm
playing something else the car oh why
not it's not a bad opening very early
Bishop f4 here by the white player huh
don't know the setup feels very solid
though is it going for queen bee three
already on very likely i will and a
queen d7 are still okay yeah 27 even
though should be fire i would probably
have to play some f 6 stuff not totally
sure about this but at least that that
gives an interesting game doesn't feel
like he's doing this Knight f6 is going
95 which is a little bit of an annoyance
I cannot take a d5 and then we should be
five wins wins the Queen
I don't want to play f6 looks weird NTS
night h4 somehow it's a bit strange the
service thing okay I'm not used to those
positions so maybe it's just my problem
that I don't know exactly what's going
on
maybe this one for Bishop t6 or
something I can also know that i have no
square how do i actually develop this
this stuff maybe bring the light around
v6 is not a bad square for it for later
queen son play ok this is this isn't so
bad i mean i took a long time to put it
on the board but I kind of like this my
night has summer camp taking here my
night has some prospects on the
queenside yeah I think oops I think I
probably want to trade yeah the night
will be really annoying only five I
don't know if I like to allow that ok
this we can see file and the e6 part of
it the night is an extremely annoying
piece on e5 so it's prevented ok yeah i
was thinking about this and I wasn't
sure if this is actually helping him I
still feel I have a good blockade if I
would get the bishop around to d5 my
position would be very good but it feels
unlikely
I think I would find you I have queen
dee 5 now that's a good one I can also
put a look maybe on d5 his night
currently is mostly passive okay that's
a direct way of doing it interesting I
can't I can take no I can take it takes
on the age create a droop 25 I wonder if
I've is a voice that a bad one
and one day ever actually takes rook e8
I won't have them actually equal there
ok let's do this is the more interesting
move anyway again I'm not sure about the
objective merits but I probably should
have decided on that quicker
hmm I'm sure what this does
angling for oxy for seems like he
doesn't mind dad yeah I see this is a
kind of a sensitive diagonal
is going to e3 here going 3-3
that stops them for the moment look to
d1 des Bishop c2 so well on my time
really down on time yeah i took a long a
lot while for some simpler decisions
let's say I don't like this night coming
there I don't know this is high morning
dear that was a good move
you
he plays as well why does he play so
well that's not fair how do I have
played this year maybe a 5 f 4 yeah I
think I have to do something not sure
check check okay now this is this is
looking good I mean not like I'm better
but i'm jang getting some play
so much for the plane what's going on
here I did am I playing so badly on my
opponents playing so we are probably
both hmm black resigns what a rotten
game this isn't all that bad I mean what
went wrong there all then quickly I
really felt like I'm okay and the engine
agrees check maybe I'm just squandering
it away yeah I'm clearly better and yeah
essentially a III is too hasty brooksy
for is just good yeah don't don't play
well even that chat in that wins Russa
form and then aged five yeah this was
the kind of like let's play an active
move and then Queen Air Force just will
end of it it's the differences between
the winner and the loss yeah he just
just has a bad position yeah I don't
know it was a difficult difficult game I
took her took a long while in the
opening and this is just a mistake c4
pretty clearly and I mean if anybody is
better here it's black and I don't know
I just took it took too long yeah by the
way if you don't believe me I can switch
this on and ask the engine I just took a
bit too long for all that when I
controller she'll throw the file and the
deep on it's not a big deal yeah just
check it just like one move one move
assistance is the whole difference here
between check winning and losing this is
a stupid move I didn't really think in
this position I just played it with
30-something seconds you sometimes just
have to make a practical
decision but the difference is really
like winning or losing yeah okay thanks
for watching